hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website.com and today we're in
round 10 of our coverage of the 2016
candidates tournament winner of this
tournament goes on to face Magnus
Carlsen in November for the World
Championships our two competitors today
at Fabiano Caruana playing the white
pieces represent the United States of
Vichy and on representing India applying
the black pieces both these players near
the top of the leaderboards vision on
tied with simply a caddy yakin with five
and a half points and car one is just
half a point behind them he just a few
rounds ago was near the bottom and he is
kind of stormed his way back with some
key victories to fight and only be 1/2
points behind so huge game for him
playing the white pieces and machine on
looking to just take sole possession
after super be a CAD hack and tied today
so he can kind of catapult himself to be
the front runner but we're going to get
started up on c4 getting into the
English opening Pawnee five kind of
somewhat plays like the reverse Sicilian
I'm Knight c3 Knight f6 Knight to f3
knight c6 so getting into the four
Knights defense pawn Ajitha
you're gonna take Kim Fein keto on the
kingside Bishop down here b4 Fink head
Oh Bishop g2 castle on the kingside
castle on the Kings side as well and
then machine on plays upon efore and
this is such an awkward spot further for
this pawn for whites have to deal with
it you know Fabiano really doesn't want
to have to move his knights right away
now and said he would like to control
the turn of the board but he hasn't
moved either of essential pawns right
now decided to go and play Knight to g5
both of his Knights are attacking the
square right here in black really only
has one defense and so he's almost
forced to play Bishop takes on c3 so
pawn recaptures here on c3 does have a
double pawn structure on the C file but
white does now have a double bishop pair
rook to e8 just solidifying at this pawn
just a little bit more and then pawn to
f3 trying to break up this pawn me
personally I'm gonna be playing pawn to
d3 here to break it up any time I fee
and get it to the king side I do like to
keep this pawn here on F to this little
pawn structure is a little bit easy
I think to defend but Ponza f3 in this
position is gonna be completely okay
especially with your opponent's dark
squared Bishop off the board you don't
have to worry as much about someone
attacking if your pawn pushes forward
here to f3 but if you were to play pawn
to d3 after the exchange right here pawn
d6 opening up the door for the lights
were at Bishop rook over here b1 trying
to control the semi-open file I think
this is gonna be a fine game for whites
but Fabiana decides to go ahead and play
pawn to f3 and then after the exchange
we have the knight come back to f3
interesting to note still haven't even
moved after 10 moves any of the central
squares from Fabiano so definitely seems
like a variation that he's studied quite
a bit both vision on and his second
which is just kind of his his helper
training coach if you will looking at
different variations many players have
variations that they are better at than
even some of the greatest grandmasters
out there so Vichy and his 2nd are both
familiar with this line specifically so
very interesting to see Fabiano go down
this line and not really try to control
the siRNA board with his pawns pawn d5
now pawn d4 now deciding after 11 moves
to go ahead and start to attack pawn
takes on c4 and then Queen to c2 and
this is kind of a novelty something
different than we don't usually see in
this position this is the book move so
far until Queen to c2 usually you're
gonna see Bishop g5 pinning down that
night right here but instead we see a
little interesting move Queen to c2 kind
of sig vision on by surprise I don't
think he's kind of prepared for this
specific move and he seemed to have a
tough time with it for awhile this she
continues pawn age 6 just solidifying
this square here on g5 which is kind of
that common move that we talked about
Bishop g5 even if he later wanted to
play Knight to g5 this does kind of stop
that in its tracks so Bishop b4 kind of
the next best alternative does want to
make sure it's aggressive in this area
of the board and there's no reason
- bring it - III blocking off his pawn
getting here - D - does absolutely
nothing at all so Bishop to f4 and then
Knight down here to e4 rook d1
protecting the center of the board
Bishop down here to f5 so this year done
although he kind of took some time
wasn't exactly sure how he was going to
approach this has a pretty active
position I do like the way Vichy and
Ana's can kind of controlling the share
of the board although he doesn't have
any central pawns which is not the
strategy you want he's doing a good job
controlling with his minor pieces so we
see Fabiano kinda doing the same thing
in return Knight to e5 now this knight
comes back to d6 upon e for forcing the
bishop back Queen e2 looking to attack
on the King side and all of a sudden
Fabiano now looks like he has kind of a
more aggressive position on board Knight
back to e7 so vichy seems to be
retreating a little bit trying to play a
little bit more defensive than trying to
control the center since he just doesn't
have any pawns you can only do so much
and then we see a pretty nice sacrifice
so if we kind of look on this board
saying hey what is what going to do my
first response would not have been take
this pawn here on h6
not not even one of my first four moves
and that's why I really like how Fabiano
approached this game he's going for gold
he recognizes he's down a half a point
he wants to represent the United States
pulling in the United States later in
November for the World Championship
there's no other reason to play Bishop
to h6 unless you're just going for after
the pawn takes we do have the Queen come
up here to h5 looking to take this pawn
here so getting two pawns for that
Bishop and just still has some pretty
aggressive pieces this rook is involved
can easily get this other rook involved
although his opponent does have now more
material it doesn't necessarily have
have all of his material involved into
the action
so this she decides to go ahead and give
up some material back so that he can
make sure that he doesn't lose the
position so Knights who have five giving
material back pawn
takes on f5 now Queen to g5 once to once
you kind of get in a tough spot you want
to take the biggest pieces off the board
that your opponent has Queens to g5 says
hey let's go ahead and sacrifice our
Queens so after the exchange here then
pawn to f6 and this kind of stops a lot
of the moves that black has to maybe
retreat his King is forced to stay on
this side of the border for whatever
wants to centralize it's gonna kind of
have to go the long way so nice little
move from here this pawn can never be
attacked by this bishop here so all in
all I do like Fabiano's his approach
even though he has his Queen off the
board
he does have still a nice little attack
on the King side Knight to e4 rook here
to e1 protecting this and then Knight
takes on c3 and this is one of those
moves where I think that she maybe
miscalculated it does seem like okay
he's he gave up you know his Knights
he's trying to get back in if we count
up the pawns you know we have six pawns
for whites we have six pawns for black
maybe he's trying to get a little
advantage here taking with his knight on
c3 but he's actually just going to end
up losing material in this spot Knight
here our rook here to c1 attacking both
the knight attacking this pawn behind it
this Bishop here on g2 is attacking this
pawn on b7 to so many threats there's no
way for vichy not to kind of hold on to
this right now he's forced to move his
Knights so Knight back here to b5 not
really going to be a great option if he
takes here on a2 still just going to
lose this pawn
he's gonna end up losing one of the
ponds up here it's just all going to be
bad later on after the bishop takes here
on b7 the roofs gonna force to move and
then rook to a1 it starts to get pretty
messy for black so vision on plays at
Knights to b5 but then Bishop b7 forcing
the rook to move the work comes over
here to d8 now we could say okay let's
bring our rook to b8 just attacking the
business portion of the bishop to move
but that's going to be completely okay
all of a sudden we just say Bishop to
d54 are attacking this pawn here on f7
which is checking the knight is
protecting it the only way also
attacking this pawn here on c4 only way
to kind of protect up here since you you
really don't want to be playing your
king to h8 because then you just take
with your knight here things start to
get really really bad but Knight to d6
does stop this but now all of a sudden
rook to c4 and even if the knight takes
then we just see check and then after
the King moves the knight is going to
fall the Knights now threatening to come
up here to d7 so we can see rook d8
trying to stop that Bishop to b5 now
attacking this rook it just gets really
really complicated you could try to stop
it if you want to with pawn c6 but just
start to gobble up material all in all
there's just too many pawns too many
passed pawns there's no way for vision
on to really deal with this in a really
good way so after Bishop to b7 a vision
on correctly decides to not worry about
rook to b8 that's gonna be tough now
instead bring us rook over here to d8
Fabiano can now play Bishop to c6 which
is also tough for vision not to deal
with attacking both the rook and the
night here on b5 after the knight takes
on d4 we see the bishop take on e8 and
then after the rook takes we see the
King start to get involved into the game
why this up in material he definitely
has a more active position on board as
well just so tough for vision odds kind
of deal with this Knight down here c2
rook here to d1 if the rook would just
take here then we could just see the
bishop take here on c2 so for those who
didn't kind of see this Bishop over here
that's kind of what he is doing so
attacking the rook here on e1 rook to d1
Bishop down here efore just centralizing
still protecting what it was and then
also just trying to protect making sure
maybe he doesn't want to deal with this
King here to f3
he's already kind of stopping the King
here to e3 because of his Knight so just
trying to thwart off any attack
nights to c4 since was being attacked by
the rook from e8 now rook down here e6
rook here to d8 just getting all up in
the business of vision on King h7 King
down here g1 rook f6 rook over here to
f1 just saying hey we're gonna go ahead
and exchange these roofs off board then
I'm gonna be have a rook and a Knights
in game versus just your two minor
pieces that's always going to kind of
favor the player with the Knights and
the ropes just can control way more of
the board and in this position mission
on decided to go ahead and resign now I
will say that in this position I am a
little bit disappointed that mission on
resigned do I think he's going to lose I
think he realizes 90% of the time I do
think he can find a draw the other 10% I
don't think he wins any I'm against
Fabiano but after only 33 moves in this
position to resign maybe he's just
trying to hold on some of his energy for
for later gamez recognizes the losing
position doesn't want to exert any more
energy but especially for the fans being
the leader in the tournament I wish he
would have fought on for just a little
while longer but in this position Bishan
on decides to go ahead and resign
Fabiano catapults all of a sudden he is
tied for first now with certain guy
cardiac and that's what vision on did
yesterday after we beat Levon Aronian
now a sudden Fabiano does the same thing
to him so we have a very tight race at
the top of the leaderboard with six
points we do have Fabiana Carmona and we
do have certain guy Cathy Hackett and
then with five and a half points fishing
on did not go anywhere and then Levon
Aronian as well who tied today so jumped
up from five to five and a half points
so the end of this tournament is going
to be exciting we have four rounds
remaining so make sure you guys check
those out it's going to be a good one
thank you guys for watching all the
other matches just if y'all are keeping
track at home ended in a tie today this
was the only victory so thanks for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video